the story that you guys have is it's
about uh what weapons trafficking
the pentagon it's about specifically
having the light i don't know yours is a
little dark
oh man it's all good specifically about
um
the 1mdb scandal and a lot of
shenanigans let's say that that
came around recently elliot broady's the
former deputy co-finance chair of the
rnc
uh might remember him as such greatest
hits as having to pay a former playboy
playmate
who bloomberg claimed um he coerced into
having an abortion 1.4 million dollars
and then he had to step down from the
rnc
i don't know anything about well you can
google that and recently he got indicted
for foreign influence crimes related to
foreign influence
surrounding the 1mdb scandal and
previously
an associate of his nikki lum davis was
indicted back in august for
similar things well we it kind of felt
like mana from heaven
we got a a cache of documents that
resulted in other
caches of documents that relate to the
1mdb scandal but specifically
we have honed in on um
invoices or quotes i guess you could say
both within this cache that concern
mrap logistics and support mrap are
armored vehicles they're
made by the u.s government armed forces
that are used they're actually mine
resistant vehicles right so they look
the size of the school bus
this particular document um
has to do with um a quote for
you know something about what is it 13
million or something
for the original quote oh the original
uh
yeah i think it might be 15 around 15.
well let's let's go
we'll we'll get in on it yeah and that's
not my camera just on the fritz right
now that'll be up in about 10 minutes
you guys can watch it so maybe we'll
come back to that so but
uh long story short what is this
government malfeasance it happened in uh
kind of the story starts in 2015 so it's
kind of a beautifully a political story
because it
overflows between administrations so
interesting yeah oh
yeah started with obama well and it
leads into
broody also had a company called
cersinist that's an open source
intelligence
company is what it's referred to and
does other things too but he was kind of
selling packages that were related to
some of these government matters well
we'll have to start from the beginning
but so before we get into that by the
way so so rocco castoro do the courtney
the documents formatter and chief of
vice
and now uh now what are you doing i'm
working for
a little outlet called scanner or senior
or scnr
it's whatever you want it to be so this
is the uh uh
this is like one of like the first
updates we've done in a really long time
about scanner
yeah so we started it a while ago it was
subverse and now it's scanner and you
guys have basically been leading
the charge on all that stuff and now you
have a big breaking story which we'll
get into
uh everybody i think well not everybody
but this is emily molly this is emily i
don't know do you want to introduce
yourself yeah
pull your mic up i'm emily molly um i
have been working for subverse scanner
since
what february 2019
about and then um yeah so now uh i was
primarily doing um on the ground
reporting uh covering
social movements civil unrest and uh
all kinds of other things and then um
yeah i started doing this full-time did
some just would typically write and do
desk presentations of everything from
like cyber security to like geopolitics
and
all kinds of like different technology
stories um while doing my on-the-ground
coverage
and now we just kind of like flipped the
format a little bit to more just field
reporting straight up field reporting
and um yeah rocco came in and helped
help set all of that up
you know how i know you guys are like
real journalists you're boring
okay let's spice it up so did you lose
any money on the election no of course
not i'm not sure
i'm not gonna get i don't know come on
now i like to gamble in a casino with
like a set amount of money for fun but
the odds are
the odds are probably more accurate than
the polls i would say yeah yeah but they
were flipping around
they were right that's odds for you yeah
well before we we'll spice it up
subscribe like button notification bell
you know what to do shows monday friday
live
um well let's let's i i do want to start
talking about with with media and stuff
though because
sure i've not had an opportunity to like
sit down with you and talk about
everything in the media
i think a lot of people need to
understand um when digital media was
like taking off you were basically
the dude i mean you can say that that's
awfully nice of me
um i mean i was certainly a pioneer if
that's not too lame of a word to use
i was at a spot where new media as they
called it back in the day which
obviously was a faulty term because it
won't be new for long
um was seen as some savior you know uh
where buzzfeed had
trending lol elois and you know vice
versa
bad boys right and then uh you know vox
was the serious hey we got as recline
over here and we have chorus this
cms product they were in other words
they were valued like tech companies
but they had no product their content
was the product they tried to show that
they had a product whether that be data
this or that
and if you look at their valuations it
follows suit where you have a bunch of
companies where people probably have
super voting shares and stuff
and now they've taken haircuts that have
brought them down to you know less than
a billion which is
really where did five billion bucks go i
started revisiting you know
well that was the largest that was the
highest valuation i mean it was like 5.7
though
was like upwards of two you know people
put a half a billion bucks in
in each of these companies essentially
anywhere from three to five hundred
you know million where'd the money go i
don't know it probably went through ad
fraud which the doj has been
investigating for years now and
something like we've been talking to
this guy dr augustine fowle who's an ad
fraud researcher out of canada he's very
well respected
a lot of his research first of all that
he references
um on his twitter is amazing and the
research he participates in is also
amazing
and we've discovered you know upwards of
80 percent
of budgets are screwed up uh in terms of
most budgets
account for 20 percent of fraud and you
should be looking at 40 to 50 percent
let's let's
let's let's slow down we'll sit down so
you've got uh like
can you name some websites specifically
that have done stuff like this well
there's
it's very difficult to classify this so
you everything from traffic assignment
letters which a variety and a bunch of
other sites digitally have written about
concerning vice which is where you
other domains trade the sales of their
ads for
for their traffic you can assign it to
yourself wait we'll slow down
like are there any specific websites
that you can name that have done things
like this
and then we'll explain what it is i
would say the majority of
new media websites during that time as
well as
i'd say any website that isn't going to
be
behind a paywall does this to an extent
the percentage to which they do it
is um what the question is here you can
be unwittingly participating in this
because
ad units sold in a weird way the general
idea is we've got
big companies big brands sure some of
the biggest digital media outlets
and the money they're making is is
fraudulent
well they're basically selling ads
telling telling brands
if you if you put the ad on our website
you're going to get what like a
100 000 clicks right but then with that
they're actually getting bots fake
clicking
it can be bots it can be what's called
ghost traffic which is actually a
legitimate click
it's very technical it's not really
important it'd be like me
it'd be like me giving you monopoly
money i'd be like hey tim here's a buck
and you give me a real quarterback
and i keep doing that right eventually
that defunds not only the market
but the us dollar and currency because
if you have
a backlog of inventory that's flowing
through the global advertising system
and you keep devaluing that based off
fake clicks that means
what does that mean i mean it means that
you're devaluing money right yeah
it's not right and it hurts journalism
because it allows
bad actors to to screw out the bottom
line
i think we started seeing so i remember
that that era
i remember like i think even shane
talked about the ceo of vice
but they were all they were all for it
basically they would assign
their traffic to other companies so that
you would think you were buying an
advertisement on
a high profile website like vice but
you're actually getting like dos.com or
something that's not fraud though that
was legal right right right yeah but
yeah
but yeah dos.com was a traffic
assignment
but advertisers frown on that now you
can't really be bona fide and do that
anymore comscore
and nielsen and all these companies have
boxed you in on that yeah so
uh have you been paying attention to
vice lately not really
i left in 2015 so i mean can you uh
you want to talk about sure i mean you
can ask me questions uh i may have to
give you a glomar
i can either what uh i i remember you
know back in the day
when i when i so when we first met
especially vice was like edgy hip cool
kind of
just doing whatever i think you think
you had a video where you were like
blowing stuff up or something anarchist
cookbook yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
and then it started to become like obama
came in you know what i mean
i mean yeah i mean there were certain i
felt like at some point maybe we were
doing
or not just them but and i don't have
any proof of this but other
outlets i know were i know that after i
left
vice worked with the saudi government
for instance i felt like they were doing
branded content for governments
and i think a lot of mainstream outlets
do that i think a lot of
supposedly independent outlets are doing
that right now and they're using botnets
it's the same crap cnn did it sure cnn
would do
it was it was i remember back in the day
cnn was accused of doing like nefarious
backroom deals with companies
sure i'm sorry with countries but then
these countries would be like no no it's
a legitimate commercial buy it's like
branded branded programming but fox news
did it with a whole seth rich thing too
i mean that's under investigation right
what was that all about
well there was a meeting between people
in a room that had a lunch
i can go ahead and name those people but
i don't want to get you sued and we're
investigating that i think you would get
sued
yeah i don't think i'm going to get sued
because it's the truth and um
you know these people all agreed
butowsky i can name because he's at the
center of that
aaron rich is currently you know going
to get to the bottom of the truth
and um i think it was a very very very
very coordinated plan that was based off
faulty i don't mean faulty a fake
intelligence report
actually made by russian and television
like this was the seth rich story
like when fox business published the
seth rich story i know you've done
videos in seth rollins yeah yeah
you've taken them down which is you know
taking the videos down you've taken a
couple down
no yes yeah i've had a bunch of videos
removed for what
i don't know this this was a big deal my
my video on the icelandic got removed as
well
yeah i they they they one day i got a
list of some someone sent me
that i had a bunch of videos my channel
were no longer there that's it
that's weird yeah it is you should
inquire about that yeah
because the videos i did on seth rich
were not particularly definitive except
for
the the when fox business ran a story
saying
they had a laptop with definitive
information or whatever like they had a
laptop that claimed
there was a communication between rich
and wikileaks or something i remember
that when
i first started visiting you know you
called me about
possibly working with subverse or doing
some different stuff
you told me straight up when you met
with assange that that basically told
you seth rich did it
no you didn't say that no then i gotta
do it
because then i went to i didn't know
emily was there with you and i went to
her and like asked her and she's like
no yeah i know dude dude okay if
if if if anything like that would have
happened i would have run out the door
or like waving the papers whoa
his videos are removed so mega guy those
videos got removed
and uh nbc used them to smear me
so kim.com you know came out yeah i
remember i signed kin.com to you
actually advice
advice yeah yeah that was fun that was
fun so uh okay we gotta slow down we
gotta make sure everybody knows the
context man
so uh when i was at vice
you uh what told me to go to new zealand
or something no no it was that um
i was i was supposed to go on some radio
show instead we'll walk back a little
bit like you know i had interviewed you
in 2011 i think
uh because we we did an uh uh issue of
ice that was called the moral compass
issue that was right around
a crazy year that was kind of a lot like
occupying right occupy wall street
and i think i had we'd done a photo
shoot actually where we put
like uh guys and guy fox mask in like
really high-end fashion
and you know we just thought it was very
uh disruptive i guess
and people seem to like it and we did we
had to do fashion shoots it was part of
the thing i'm not a
fashion shoot guy but that was part of
my job
and got us money so um you know i think
i might have met you around that time
because we were doing a lot of stuff
around there and
i think you know you're reluctant at
first to get do an interview
and get the interview which i don't know
that's why i want to yeah yeah and you
were like
you know you're very um rightfully so i
think you know very um cautious about
mainstream
and media and uh even for vice at the
time this was 2011 right
so like um and you know this is before
the hbo show this before things i
started a device where
gavin had just gotten booted i've really
never met gavin except
you can talk about later than one time i
did and um
and uh you know i didn't really realize
what was going on was 20 2005
essentially and um
started as an editorial assistant for
thomas morton who's one of my favorite
people ever
and um had the right of my life where i
became editor-in-chief years later
probably because they had no one else to
take
so i i was supposed to go on some radio
program in minnesota or something sure
like it was a big national effort
and then uh i guess you told them to
send me to new zealand because
i knew but we got to back up though
because like i told vice news to hire
you
because they were like trying to poach
my people that i was working with other
had
they just put jason mojica uh which we
won't get into that right now you can
google who he is
on board and um you know i thought to
myself
well they need a lot of content filled
they have no idea what they're talking
about with news
they're bringing that guy on i'm you
know i know tim's gonna annoy the [ __ ]
out of this guy no
so shane said there was no vice news
before me
yeah but that's there was i built the
entire budget no no no but there was
like
the they would they would run kind of
they would put vice news on it but the
official channel was supposed to be
the things that didn't make hbo that's
what shane said
sure once it got funded but hbo wasn't
around for about a year before vice news
but so when after sorry after advising
then they got funded i
actually funded i had to talk to them i
don't
want to name everybody and drag
everybody through like they're there's
i'm not gonna name certain people but uh
i didn't negotiate with them on actually
doing the on-the-ground livestream stuff
because they didn't want to do it no
that's not true because i told them you
should hire this kid to do live streams
i was doing live
they told me they didn't want to well
that didn't didn't really work out that
way did it no it didn't i know
probably because you were telling them i
was and then i said why aren't you going
to go send them you guys want big hits
you're trying to poach my people
send him to kim.com and it got ice and
then they wouldn't fund it
i funded it i said fine here you go and
you went i kind of regret that because
the video should have been higher
production but
they they had they had this thing there
where it was like constantly
begrudgingly doing things you know so
whatever and then you
immediately that's the media you can't
complain about that you've got to play
the game if you're going okay okay but
we were talking about soldier the seth
rich stuff all right
so kim.com right
i i had uh i i i think it i'm not gonna
say i don't wanna say any names but
one of the main directors come to me and
says do you want to go to new zealand at
interview kim.com
like the famous hacker guy yeah and i
knew a bit i knew a decent amount about
him already sure and the concern was
that the person they had normally had do
interviews didn't know anything about
these people i guess
someone interviewed assange before and
it wasn't like
substantive it wasn't good so i actually
knew a ton and then i don't know
you know what could pass well we have to
go back in time when kim.com was
this was right right when he was being
well it was around the mega upload stuff
the mega upload stuff so this is before
cam.com was any sort of political
spokesperson or force in any which way
shape or form except for like
the same wavelength as assange in terms
of data rights and right freedom right
he got raided by what like the mpaa
right in new zealand right
so for those that don't know kim.com was
an internet enter entrepreneur never set
foot in the united states
launched a a company called mega upload
where you could
host you could it was it's like google
drive
right before there was a before that was
wheel drive but people were using it for
for piracy
you could upload a video and then search
it and find movies
so sure enough they accused him of being
a pirate and then eventually they
raided his mansion compound in new
zealand and it was american interests
with the new zealand government that did
it well i would imagine new zealand
probably had some interest in that too
for sure in their their partner
countries but yes
sure so i ended up uh interviewing with
uh interviewing the guy we did the video
the video took off it did really really
well
and then where did you want to go you
want you wanted to go back in time but
we were talking about that was it i
wanted to give it some context yeah
right right right right
right so uh since kim.com amplified the
seth rich story so much you know right
and he's so
sorry so then there was this uh dnc
uh email leak and how did this how did
this even
this this like idea emerge it was
assange right he was doing an interview
and they asked him
no there was a a fake
srv or svr i always get it confused
russian intelligence report
but it was made by russian intelligence
and this is from the mouth
of the the prosecutor essentially
working on the case the term
you know it's and she's retired it's it
uh michael
it's coughed at a great thing called
conspiracy land on this yeah
i think your friend cassandra's on that
too but and you know she had something
very close to that so did luke rodowsky
who
i also know from back in the day's
invites yeah i still know luke we had
something on this
well he was one of the very first people
to run a story by alice
donovan donovan you know i think i might
get this wrong sorry i didn't
well yeah there were there were some
posts made on we are change um
alice donovan i believe was the first
one well alice donovan's named in
both the mueller report in which we
don't need to get into that whole thing
but it's very clear when you look at the
previous postings before seth rich that
it's a russian propaganda vehicle right
and what else did they talk about like
pro-assad stuff
uh yeah apparently there was uh certain
pro-assad talking points i guess being
laundered through various blogs
um and i think alice donovan was also
one of the
one of the authors interesting and it
was being laundered through like places
like
sputnik and rt which sandra was working
at but we know
that like that a intelligence report a
fake one
that was used in collusion with a group
of individuals one being the fox news
reporter that
initially reported the story that had
retract and now they're all there's a
bunch of lawsuits for it but
etcetera yeah so there was it was it was
i think it was a fox business article
claiming that his laptop had
communications with wikileaks
and that was the basis for something i
talked about and then someone
asked me in like a live stream did i
think it was true or not and i was like
uh 60
you know 70 or whatever and we literally
had an article from fox saying that they
were communications and that was the
base of it
yeah that was used by nbc to smear me
claiming i was pushing the conspiracy
but i was also saying you know kim.com
is claiming it's true and i i
i'm pretty sure i said in every video
these things never pan out
stuff like this doesn't happen the
likelihood there's evidence is probably
slim to none
but i don't think kim.com is a liar i've
met the guy i've talked to him
and so i guess we'll you know we'll see
how this you know plays out and then
at some point yeah a bunch of videos got
purged for my channel
what you know what's really irksome
about this is that i discovered it
because i had a video i produced in
norway called the istal woman
of norway this is just me going to
bergen norway
and talking but this is the craziest
thing i was talking to local researchers
about a woman who was found dead
in the just outside of the city of
bergen she was like found face down in a
fire pit
dead of smoke inhalation and they found
a suitcase full of like passports and a
bunch of other stuff
it's a very famous like it's not a
conspiracy story because it literally
happened
they just don't know who she was there's
also the story do you know the story of
talmud shud
it sounds familiar guy in australia
washes up on shore yeah
and then he's got a bunch of passports
so i just talked to some locals
and like you know we were walking around
in bergen and we asked some locals
what's a good story and they said ooh
the istal woman the ice woman
that video's gone and i love showing it
to people because it was just
a silly mystery video there was like all
we did was talk folklore with locals
i went on my channel because i would
like check out this really old video i
made it was really fun
gone do you know a backup of it no no no
no
so uh nowadays all of it all my videos
are produced are backed up on like bit
shoot
or minds.com but that was uh but back
then and so then someone sent me an
email
saying like i mentioned it and they're
like i went through and checked and
there was something like 30 videos that
had been removed from my channel without
me knowing
very interesting i have some i have some
ideas about
uh google and what google wants
and what facebook wants and what the big
tech companies are doing
uh and a simple way to put it is why for
some reason my channel doesn't get
removed
well i've had my some of my videos have
over 15 million views and if you google
my name you will not be able to find
them
yeah you explained that one too and
three of them have been removed
you know we had uh do you know who alan
bakari is
uh no breitbart tech reporter okay he we
had him in he wrote a book and he talked
about
that cassandra's friend yeah yeah he
talked about how
facebook has uh and i'm probably gonna
you know butcher what he was telling me
so just fact check this
that they're trying they try to figure
out what kind of content de-radicalizes
people
and then promote it as much as possible
that's weird yup
that's so either which way it's like a
graphic so
then when i hear like a bunch of my
videos got removed
but it's i don't want to get you know
too conspiratorial
well yeah i guess you know but at the
same time it's like if they're doing
that
and there's no explanation there should
be an investigation
into like why videos are gone well what
you just said if if they're doing the
de-radicalization or they're promoting
the algorithm for some reason promotes
and i'm not saying it's a human choice
somehow it gets flipped in a way that
inadvertently promotes radicalization
videos like we need to know about that
as people we need to have access to that
data publicly
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free if you want to listen
to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all next time
you